a cosmic OD is mo ve lovin it as Kelvin
I found out I want to know what the best
thing about the show has been so far
there's like so many things that have
been the best part of this show right so
many that I can't even count that's okay
because this nine year olds claim to
fame is spelling across competed in his
first felony at two at three he became a
member of the high IQ Society Mensa when
he was six he reached spell ever D
status has the youngest boy ever to
compete in the Scripps National Spelling
Bee
don't unscrew just pull it down on tap
there you go right there there you go
you're the youngest competitor on this
very special edition of Dancing with the
Stars
I just turned nine but fiercest what do
you think we're the youngest thank you
discomfort Whitney easier or harder than
Dancing with their own partner I would
say probably harder because we can't be
there physically with them we have to
just be this crazy stage mom on stage
and be like do go do do you think you
have a shot at taking home the
Mirrorball trophy
and we sort of have a little advantage
into it and that's basically cuteness
[Music]